California family living in a fake
whorehouse says it's turning into a
real-life nightmare this Los Angeles
mansion was featured in the first season
of the hit TV show American Horror Story
its new owners are now suing the former
owner and the real estate company
because they say they were never told
that crowds of obsessive fans traveled
to see it Jamie yuccas is outside the
house Jamie good morning might have made
a difference if they knew that
information absolutely a good morning it
is one of the things the owners say they
had to do they had to put up a fence to
try to keep out the hundreds of American
Horror Story fans who show up to get a
glimpse of the house but you can see it
hasn't worked the fans have actually
tried to scale the fence and they've
tried to scale the walls of the house
itself the couple says if they had known
that that was going to happen they never
would have moved in
ornate and classically creepy this Los
Angeles cultural landmark the rosenheim
mansion was an ideal setting for the
terrifying first season of American
Horror Story so when you guys walked up
to the house but actually living there
has become a different kind of Horror
Story for the homes owners married
couple Ernst von Schwarz and Angela
Oakenfold what do you see on a daily
basis just groups of people turning up
in cars taking selfies taking videos do
you recognize the house Steven Steven
John American Horror Story
we had several break-ins we had on three
four occasions just in the last year to
call the police the owners say fans have
climb fences and one perched on their
ledge some teenagers literally got a
lift from a garbage truck driver he put
them in the crane and he elevated it and
I'm in my bathroom and I looked at my
bathroom window and there's like teenage
girls screaming in at me and nobody told
you at all this has been an American
Horror Story we go with the house of
course and like everybody else for two
and if you google the house you find a
lot of movies have been filmed yeah
lastly the American Horror Story which I
have never seen you had never seen they
say their realtor and the homes former
owner should have alerted them about the
show's rabid fans they're now suing both
the former owner and their realtor for
damages including the cost of a
permanent fence or hedge to secure their
privacy the realtor issued a statement I
have no doubt that the truthful facts of
this case will resolve this matter in
our favor we feel like we they cheated
us we want to live you of course but it
is very difficult especially since we
don't feel safe
the couple also hopes to recoup the
losses to the property's value we tried
contacting the sellers attorney but they
haven't gotten back to us we also called
a real estate attorney who told us that
it would be the sellers legal obligation
to disclose any noises or nuisances in
the neighborhood Norah
alright Jamie thanks well they if they
try and sell it they may have some
trouble that we all know of the owners
names though first van Schwartz and
Angela oakenfold
might be hard to sell that and all